the anti-grooming law in florida has
liberal teachers up in arms this whole
class is going to feel my wrath they are
absolutely furious that they are no
longer allowed to preach transgenderism
to preschoolers through third grade me
frankly i think we should extend it to
fourth grade to fifth grade i think we
can push it up a little bit but at least
the law is a start and the liberals are
losing their minds they are taking to
tick-tock to express their dismay and
their fury this video is brought to you
by expressvpn more from them in a moment
first though let's take a look at some
of these teachers my producers have
compiled all of these tick tocks and
they want me to figure out which one is
most likely to be fired and possibly
prosecuted under this new florida law
take it away a four-year-old in my class
today
was naming all the girls in class
and then she said my name
and i just tell her i'm not a girl don't
include me
and then another four-year-old whipped
around like
mixed kid is a people
more than one individual so this woman
apparently is still teaching it she's
still you're not allowed to teach
transgenderism but she is still teaching
it
she obviously should not be teaching
students because this woman doesn't know
the difference between a boy and a girl
and so if you don't know the difference
between a boy and a girl you don't know
much of anything and so you don't have
anything to teach to the students this
is no affront to this confused person
she should see a psychiatrist but it's
not up to five-year-olds to solve that
problem for her or worse to indulge her
delusions boys have a penis girls have a
vengeance
next one
so there's definitely a different gender
euphoria that comes with getting clocked
by like queer youth there was this kid
that walked by my workspace today and um
had met them before we just started
talking and they were like
i'm i think i really like you and i was
like oh thanks
um i'm glad i make a good first
impression
i haven't gotten their name yet so i ask
and
then they ask my name i said my name is
parker
then they look at me and they're like uh
can i get your pronouns
just call me right away
and i have my pronouns up on a
whiteboard behind me so i point at it
and they were like
oh
okay i'm just so like clearly so excited
and so i asked back i'm like okay what
about yours and
and there and they were like oh any any
uh i said okay
so this person is a groomer
obviously i'm not allowed within 100
yards of the school we use the phrase
groomer because just at a very basic
level if you're having conversations
with little kids about sex and then
hiding those conversations from the kids
parents you you just are a groomer and
you're grooming them into a kind of
sexual ideology and you're
indoctrinating them so i i defend the
use of the term but when we say groomer
we're not saying that every one of these
teachers is
trying to get jiggy with the kids
[Music]
right or probably very few of them are
trying to get jiggy with the kids when i
watch this video i think uh there's
something weird going on here even
beyond the ideology first this woman i
guess is she a woman probably this woman
uses the phrase gender euphoria
so you're gender dysphoria which is when
you're confused you're a man you think
you're a woman you're very very upset
about that
but gender euphoria that would be this
great surge of pleasure
right so she says i got this great
pleasure because a
a transgender queer youth or whatever
phrase she uses came up to me and was
talking to me and said that said this
person really likes me and she uses the
pronoun they because she doesn't want to
say if if it's a boy or a girl
says yeah he really liked me and i said
yeah what are your pronouns yeah you
tell me you're so this is just really
creepy stuff and you're talking about
euphoria and you're talking about how
you like it when little kids really like
you and so so this this is kind of a
different level for most teachers when
they're indoctrinating kids into this
transgender stuff they should simply be
fired and kept away from classrooms in
other cases
you might want to take things to the
next level in terms of investigation
and when when you have a teacher talking
about how much she loves it when when
little kids like her and start talking
about her sexual pronouns and sexual
desires and things that's another level
maybe
maybe then you gotta call the cops next
one if you wanna stop me you're gonna
have to [ __ ]
kill me
uh
i don't have very much to say here
i don't want to kill this person doubt
it what i want to do to this person is
uh bring her back into accord with
reality and so maybe take her to some
classes maybe sit down have coffee with
her say no boys or boys and girls or
girls i don't we don't need to kill you
we all need to
come back to reality and reject this
crazy ideology which
has only existed for about five minutes
now but if you're having emotional
outbursts and saying kill me kill me
then you should not be in front of
little kids in the classroom for sure
this is the argument that the libs are
always making they're saying if we don't
trans the five-year-olds why they're
going to kill themselves and it's the
same argument that a emotionally abusive
boyfriends and girlfriends make if you
ever leave me i'm gonna kill myself
that's not an acceptable way to have a
relationship with a girlfriend or
boyfriend or husband or wife much less
between a teacher and a student
no one wants to kill anybody we just we
just want you to calm down
and come back to earth
welcome to earth now
one way to do that
is to
bring the political order back into some
reality but it's very unpopular now to
do that when you look up maybe
conservative things on the internet
people are going to be after you which
is why you got to check out expressvpn
right now go to
expressvpn.com
michael yt head on over there to help
protect your data from being tracked
you've got to check out expressvpn this
is the vpn i use i keep it on all of my
devices whenever i go online
when you search for something when you
watch a video when you click a link that
is all being tracked it's being tracked
right now by three letter agencies by
big tech or by both
anytime they want to they can match your
activity to your true identity using
your device's unique ip address but when
you turn on expressvpn boom that's gone
your identity is anonymized with a
secure vpn server we know that the
people who are looking at our data don't
like us
we know they want to destroy us we know
that they don't like our political views
so stop handing over your data to the
government and big tech companies defend
your rights with the same vpn that i use
expressvpn.com
michael yt get three extra months for
free or click the link in the
description below
all right let's keep going i just want
to go ahead and state that i would
rather lose my job than out one of my
students to their families
being a safe person and a safe place for
kids that don't have that at home is one
of the best parts of being a teacher
um so yeah i'm not doing it i don't know
fire me sue me take me to jail i'm not
doing it
okay so at least this woman is
acknowledging what the law does and
she's just saying i'm just going to
violate the law because my favorite part
of being a teacher is having sexual
conversations with my students that
their parents don't know about so she's
saying and she's saying it verbatim when
people tell you who they are believe
them so i can't really knock her here i
can knock her for her views and her
desires which are disordered and creepy
and weird but at least she's honest at
least she's not beating around the bush
all right final video
as an elementary school teacher in
florida
um
this new bill has really been weighing
on me a lot
i
teach first grade
which means my classroom is one of the
ones that will be directly affected
um
one of the things that teachers always
do with back to school night and
meet the teacher and things like that is
they like send home this cute little
like meet the teacher thing where it has
like a little bio about us
some of our favorite stuff just
so that you know who we are
how do i do that next year
do i
lie
and
not talk about my marriage why not
do i pretend i'm single
do i invalidate my spouse's stance
as a trans femme person
what am i supposed to do
what am i supposed to do uh you're
supposed to not talk about your sex to
little kids it's quite simple really do
you not have any other aspect of your
identity do i not talk about my i don't
know if this woman actually is married
or if she's just in some kind of strange
relationship with a trans poly octagonal
whatever eight stunning angles but
regardless it doesn't matter you don't
need to talk about your sex life to the
parents weirdo you don't have to do it
you don't i'm
this is i don't mean to i don't mean to
insult you i don't i'm trying to help
you here there's more to life than who
you like to stop
okay
stop it
stop pretending that your whole
identity is your libido
it's not you got more you got more going
on or at least you should so which of
these teachers
is
the most likely to end up fired and or
in a jail cell i think it's that number
two teacher the one who said yeah this
queer youth came up to me today and i
was like yo i like you
yeah hey cool yeah what's your pronouns
yeah that one is the creepiest by far so
i think she gets number one with an
honorary mention for number two who says
i'm gonna violate the law come sue me
people should in order for these laws to
have some teeth we need to actually
enforce them and the law is extremely
popular we don't want these people
transiting the kids is that too much to
ask
according to them it is well too bad
we've got the political power for now we
should use it see you next time
[Music]
[Music]